if you guys could body swap with any
member of the Jumanji crew and learn
more about what they do or gain their
skills who would it be and why Jake
oh go Jake our director director Jake
crew and I just wanna be in Jake's egg
to really understand how he sees this
world the ad Matt revving cop adsr also
just so undervalued there are the unsung
heroes of productions
imagine having to be the person that's
like come on come on come on it's like I
just don't know how you can do that in
today exactly it's a hard job well I
think I would did body-swapping the DP
he was like amazing
I'd go with Jilla our cinematographer
just see let's see how he sees the world
it's an amazing I may be lighting
lighting is better you later yeah yeah
I'm fascinated by how how what does it
do Pete and the lighting
I'm going no it's okay just go editor
editor I love post-production on films
and being able to sit in a nice
comfortable room with everything that I
want food wise and just get to
constructible movie it's the greatest
exam and after-effects kind of girl and
no avid oh wow I think his name is Eddie
Eddie Eddie George Wythe actually go as
Kevin I'd want to go as Kevin I know she
seems disappointed I understand I think
the disappointment comes from the fact
that we need some other body SWAT movie
were you to just play each other
something about that feels so right it
does feel right right it feels right so
I'll kick it off by becoming Kevin yeah
very very easy for me to do the same I
would just like to know what it's like
to be you know intellectually inferior
and physically inferior and emotionally
stunted